[Music]
advertising is everywhere and what you
read what you watch what you eat what
you wear
they're in the sky they're on the ground
they're in the water our economy thrives
on you buying more and more and more
even though you don't need anymore and
oh yeah you're in debt
the goal of advertising is simple get
you to buy a product to make you say yes
I want this
I knew this my life will be better with
this retro cowbell dispenser but a mason
jar - that is adorable this is the mug
that won't fall over watch this it fell
- Phil we wanted to learn how
advertisers capture our attention and
get us to buy stuff we don't even really
need so we turned to Jonas Sachs
an advertising executive and co-founder
of free-range studios to explain a few
ways brands get into our heads
how do ads tell us who we are or give us
tell us who we should be we see 3,500 of
them a day and the majority of them
basically tell us you suck and if you
don't buy this product you're not going
to be rich enough smart enough hot
enough and so we walk around being told
3,500 times a day how deficient and lame
we are are there an additive stuck out
in your mind the number-one most shared
advertisement on YouTube of all time in
that dub real beauty sketches add they
make the real beauty sketches it's all
about how women are so much more
beautiful than they think they are
through the stunt of a police artist
who's sketching them tell me about your
hair they make a picture of what they
think they look like which is what a
stranger things kind of have a fat
rounder face people are saying listen
they're reaching hundreds of millions of
people with a positive message about
beauty people want to share they say oh
those are my values that's my idea and
then you start buying the soap because
you share this value
No
so this is one of those classic shop
therapy ads that you know parent to it
is hard drinking coke is easy
you need to speak to people and level of
identity to speak people on level of
emotion there are millions of people
we're going to sit there and be like
yeah that's my truth that's it it's
totally me
thanks coke why use Beckham
advertisements tell you not that this
product does this thing it's that people
like this use this product if you want
to be like these kind of people use this
product and you're instantly one of them
you know we all want heroes in our lives
and we want to know how to be more like
those heroes and you know watching
sports and watching movies that these
guys are in we don't necessarily know
how to be more like them but
advertisements tell us how to be are you
up for whatever don't answer
grab a Bud Light and chilli try new
things make new friends it means all
just crafted around creating a gap you
know you don't have enough you don't
have what's right it's not necessarily
even at the audience of the sitting at
home and saying oh man I need spend more
time in the club it's like saying
they're saying everybody else is in the
club and why aren't you there so
advertising is just a constant fear of
missing out there's a huge amount of
that well
advertisers are like crappy friends they
make us feel needy ugly and uncool but
we keep him around anyway this is a
beautiful moment sure could use a coke
you
[Music]